apple daily to close
last pro-democracy hong kong newspaper
hong kong's sole remaining pro-democracy
newspaper will publish its last edition
thursday
forced to shut down after five editors
and executives were arrested and
millions of dollars in assets were
frozen
as part of china's increasing crackdown
on dissent in the semi-autonomous city
the silencing of a pro
prominent pro-democracy voice is the
latest sign of china's determination to
exert greater control over the city long
known for its freedoms after huge
anti-government protests during 2019
shook the government since then beijing
has imposed a strict national security
law
using the arrest of the newspaper
employees and revamped hong kong's
election laws to keep
opposition voices out of the legislator
apple daily was founded by tycoon jimmy
ly
in 1995 just two years after before
britain handed hong kong
back to china and initially was a
tabloid known
for celebrity gossip ballet had also
always portrayed the paper as an
advocate of western values and said it
should shine a light on snakes
insects mice and ants in the dark
according to the paper what can you say
about that well i mean look
hong kong's gone fully it's fully gone
and the thing about it is it goes back
to the the same problem we just talked
about
hsbc so apple daily hsbc apple daily
shut down
hs hsbc is still going what does hsbc do
they basically funnel us dollars in
into hong kong and then those get
exchanged
into china to for the people with bank
of china so hsbc
is basically the external bank of the
chinese communist party that
that's what's going on fully operational
so
while democracy is being shut down free
speech is being shut down
remember what i said what if the mafia
owned the fed
this is what's going on the chinese
communist party in a way owns a fed
because they own
hsbc which is basically using the hong
kong dollar
to get hard currency into china
and a hard currency means our dollars i
mean this
this is this is uh we have built the
perfect
system the perfect financial and
economic system
to allow our economy to be destroyed and
the chinese communist party built the
perfect economic and financial system
in order to destroy our economy it just
it's it's synergistic it works together
and so
apple daily goes on everybody says oh
this is terrible but
we're going to still pump billions of
dollars into hong kong because
people in wall street are getting fat on
that i'm going to call a guy here edgar
edgar if you're ready i'm calling you
did you say i have to facetime him
facetime audio so do i just press audio
or facetime
tell me where to go
okay let's go uh
we need kai's intelligence guy all right
let me lower this a little bit
hello edgar can you hear us yeah yeah
fantastic so thank you for uh
the message back and forth edgar you
were saying that you were in hong kong
now you can't go back can you kind of
walk us through what the conditions are
tell us a little bit about your
background and what the conditions are
currently right now in hong kong
um so i'll tell you a little bit about
my background first i was born and
raised in hong kong
i studied in an international school
there for many years and then i moved to
the uk
and i now live in the uk and i go back
to hong kong frequently
and from my perspective on hong kong you
know
when i was born i was born after the
handover so obviously i lived in hong
kong that was never ruled by
the british and it was under a one
country
two systems treaty but the problem with
that treaty now is no more than a
historical document
um because for example when hong kong in
was uh 27 percent share of china's gdp
now it's only worth 2.9 percent so hong
kong's insignificant now in that terms
and they're really trying to bring hong
kong in um and trying to incorporate
them into the kind of the greater bay
area which is
you know a very big economic area in
china so
in that sense they're trying to bring
stability
and they have in a sense brought
stability but hong kong has definitely
changed um
from when i was there edgar why is why
is china so afraid of hong kong to the
average person we see this stuff and
you know you hear celebrities you know
you see the actor cena who comes out and
apologizes in chinese i am so sorry to
even think about
comparing the two together you know why
is china so worried about
hong kong um i think
they're worried about hong kong because
hong kong
was in a sense free when i was there in
a sense the media was free
you know you had apple daily you had
news reporting
and i would say you know the economy was
good people were good
the one country two systems thing wasn't
bad up to a certain point
and then now you know they they they
squash dissident
you know they squashed any opposition i
think
you know the chief executive carrie lamb
um a lot of people have mixed opinions
on her i won't give my opinion
but um a lot of people do have mixed
opinions on her
and you know everything's changed now
you know for example the police force
used to be one of the most respected in
the world
now they're one of the most feared you
know people are very scared of them
people are very scared to speak up and
people are very afraid to say
anything at all this you're saying poli
the chinese police
no no hong kong police hong kong police
used to be very respected but now
you know it's it's totally different
from what it was you know when it was
ruled under the british you had a lot of
british officers
you know a lot of british seniors in the
police force now they've been replaced
by local chinese
and they're trying to do that because
china is trying to in a sense tighten
its grip on hong kong
and they have successfully done that and
you know as your guest was right hong
kong in a sense is lost
but you know if you don't say anything
hong kong's the perfect place to live
if you do say something then you know
it's not the place for you well it's the
same in china
it's the same in china if you don't say
anything about the government you're
fine
absolutely absolutely and um where i
used to live in hong kong i
uh used to live right next to the border
near shenzhen
and as you know it was a special
economic zone and i've seen it get built
from a very small kind of uh town to a
really major city
and you know there was a difference
between hong kong and china but
you know nowadays there's not that much
of a difference apart from a border but
it's not really much of a border
if anything there's not much of a border
right now if anything so
uh for for for you with what business
you're in right now and what you're
doing right now what are your thoughts
about what just happened with apple
daily
um so personally i just graduated from
university and
um i'm in the sales position at the
moment and when i saw the apple daily
news come out
you know obviously a lot of people were
upset about it you know a lot of people
are afraid because
i believe the owner jimmy lies his name
has been tried in a courts
that um without any uh without any
people there it's just
china appoints a judge and then the
judge kind of rules in china's favor
and you know there's no you know it's
it's hard to say
100 what it's like in the courtroom and
everything but i definitely think you
know things have changed
you know that kind of freedom of press
you know that kind of justice system
that the british put there has been
taken away so a lot has changed in hong
kong for sure
awesome any questions from euron uh adam
i just have one question yeah
how ugly can this get meaning
if you try to silence people in america
as an example
there's going to be people saying i'll
say what i want freedom liberty like
i'll you know i'll talk
say what you want there's probably
people you said you can't as long as you
don't say anything
if you're in hong kong and you're a
pro-democracy person you want to voice
your opinion
like is that completely done with or how
ugly can this get give the flip side if
the people revolt like what could
possibly happen
how ugly did this get from now on people
can't revolt it's totally quashed you
know
the the situation in hong kong is in
terms of democracies you know very bleak
in that sense you know
and you know in britain for example
we've launched a
bnos scheme so i believe people with bno
passports are eligible to come to the uk
and that's really angered uh china for
example because lithuania just
said they could they'll take con
counters yeah and you know obviously
it's it's it's
uh it's it's something china doesn't
like because
um a lot of chinese students a lot of
very smart people in hong kong are
emigrating out of
uh hong kong and you know obviously
that's gonna harm the economy but i
think from now on
uh hong kong's definitely changed and
people should look to taiwan because i
think that is definitely
the next thing to come is he allowed to
go back to hong kong or
the fact that he's even talking are you
are you able to go back to hong kong or
and what happens if you do
i am able to go back to hong kong and
you know
in in terms of you know what i say i'm
not saying anything controversial here
i'm just
i'm stating facts straight facts here
and so you know
i think you know if i do arrive in hong
kong um i would be allowed in but
there's this national security law
extends to the globe basically if you're
in america you say something if you say
something against hong kong you can end
up
they don't they don't like that then
they'll put you in prison if you land in
hong kong
or china so as an american if i'm like i
don't like what's going on in hong kong
and i go visit hong kong
i end up in jail straight well it's it's
not the sense that you say oh i don't
like but if you're very vocal about it
um you know you might have some trouble
when you go to hong kong or
i think you're safe adam i think we may
not be but i think you're safe
edgar any final any final thoughts for
us because uh
anything else you want to tell the
listeners yeah i just want to say one
thing um
you know hong kong was a really amazing
city in the sense that
you know hong kong had low taxes it was
semi-free you know healthcare was
basically almost free and they also had
private health care
and you know i think hong kong was a
very you know economically was very good
but obviously now
the prospects of hong kong has
definitely kind of gone down
but you know you never know what might
happen in the future but i definitely
think taiwan is the next kind of
taiwan's um danger point for the world
what does that mean exactly a danger
point for the world next target
china one by one by one is taking place
and uh for example you've got india
you got you got japan you got the us and
possibly australia
and if china you know they have been
very vocal that they might
launch an attack on taiwan if they do
japan recently came out with a
uh a statement or something that said
that they would
strategically back taiwan but you know
no one's for sure or knowing or knows
that if that's going to happen so you
just gotta wait and see for that
edgar thank you for your time appreciate
you buddy thank you thank you very much
take care bye-bye bye-bye
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye